vous vous demandiez certainement
commander keen que vous aviez tant de
mal à faire tomber on avait si peu à se
remettre d'aplomb et bien vous voyez
vous savez désormais et comment on les
ramasse il vous reste à apprendre à
lancer la boule c'est presque aussi
facile que de danser le twist c'est
aussi indispensable à notre époque nous
en conviendrons il a différentes
manières la manière athlétique
la manière me couler efficace mais en
réalité plus les exégètes de la boule
américaine bull viron il y a surtout la
bonne manière et la mauvaise voie là
brive et ça n'était pas très en forme
hier soir j'étais pourtant à
l'international bowling de lyon une
compétition sérieuse patronné par une
grande marque de champagne de reims 60
engagés connurent des fortunes diverses
ainsi que la cour peut donc de
l'élimination et finalement c'est
monsieur le verte avec un score jamais
atteint qui l'emporta sur les six
finalistes
monsieur de werth a donc établi un
record en record
essayer de le battre si vous voulez